well what a wonderful podcast how what's
the time that's very close to two hours
yeah is that the record hand you know
what I know you're gonna cut it down
nothing about this podcast that I need
to cut out there was that one part we
used to drop the anymore with like a
hard you guys should probably cut that
that's not gonna be caught that nothing
about this pockets be caught and I may
say that the pleasure was all mine thank
you so much my pleasure
no I'm being real did you have a good
time you or no and then great I love
their comfortable ride like I'm being
sarcastic but like the first time we sat
down I thought I had a wonderful time
I felt the same way you know I felt like
it flowed and I felt like nothing was
forced and I tried to be boring myself
it came out organic powerful the people
boring yeah and while I also learned
that um Tiger belly is the thing is that
my foundation mm-hmm and that's another
thing that I found out you know from you
and I also found out that um you guys
are cool you know so give them a round
of applause guys up anything you want to
promote aside from h3 know our dog
shredder dog shredders the best he's the
cutest little guy you loved I've met
shredder yeah he's like life-changing
yes no I just think I'll uh I love
everything I love this I love this you
guys Rock thanks for having us here kids
yeah weird were actually trying we
talked about a little bit on the podcast
that everyone around us is having kids
and [ __ ] now babies and doing all the
[ __ ] and it's just it's not happening
for us yet but we're trying yeah I'm
gonna go squirt in a cup soon yes I'm
gonna freeze my eggs this year oh really
this in case yeah I oh these are
complete
it seems average from what I've seen
it's not like it's not like Elmer's glue
or it seems like you do like marshmallow
style no they pick a spot like you could
like make sure that a compliment are you
complimenting me I just feel like you
have your you know I can serve as a
compliment but I think it really thick
condense what's the theory he thinks
that it somehow I don't know what sure
come look like really thick and very
small baby dollop yeah now do you have
ever seen I don't even think it could be
measured but it's thick so it's
basically coat in its condensed down
will do you but it's not you can see the
white right I have a good vault I have
good volume I've you ever smelled your
own come well I haven't even like
directly gone up to my nose but like
sometimes you'll jizz in a rag and you
get you can smell after it dries yeah it
smells like to me chlorine I don't smell
chlorine yeah yeah III I find it to be a
pleasant smell do you I don't like it at
all come when I smell that I'm like it
smells like rock bottom if I'm being
honest I come out of your body right
it's probably up there right that's a
pleasant if I had the smell of all the
things to come like [ __ ] is probably the
rock bottom yeah but I mean I don't
smoke I generally don't [ __ ] on the
floor of mine I understand would you
ever [ __ ] and then look at and go yeah
yeah every time give me - oh yeah you
have to look anyway sometimes I wipe too
much I can't see it though you know what
I did the other day you know what you
don't happens to me that's that's cool I
clinched it
yeah gap I like a ship advanced it and
the other like I'll to tempt it wouldn't
come out so basically I just have to
open [ __ ] with like a little bit of
poop grab it
I know you have to grease [ __ ] about you
push it all the way out and then you
grab it wait what did you do have to
grab it I love ya I wait for the next
[ __ ] the next time becomes the front
of the next human centipede back in your
[ __ ] as a factory okay so I'm making
Twinkies for instance right
so one Twinkie is not fully formed right
I stick it you know and then the back
end of that Twinkie the front end of the
neutral you can't I've gotta suck it
back in or you it you're in or you're
out
sometimes he's saying that it's still at
the front of the necks of the line you
need to refrigerate it I'll tell you why
I know it's not a Batman from your app
you know [ __ ]
oh how do you get [ __ ] the skid mark
I don't I do well thing is that it's not
all the way back in your ass oh why sure
that's not what it is what it is is it's
a little bit open and there's still the
tail end of it is uncomfortable I don't
like it okay but that's how we're gonna
end the projects do I sometimes when I'm
I wrote baby sometimes I don't I let it
hang you always end with it's becoming a
moral problem
apparently the flushable baby wipes are
not flexible they're not they're lying
to come kind of a big conflict really
because I'm a huge Bay I love I live and
die by the baby wave dude you drive
first and the baby one can't start wet
otherwise your whole world is broken
crazy
I'd start wet but anyway Rich's own you
start with wet Twila to Shane he's
beautiful to pay are you going with
paper towels he's slow nodding right now
how many times do you wipe on us
traction he needs traction I'm about to
say something so truthful to you
I'm gonna say something so truthful to
you it's gonna boggle my mind no one
ever taught me how to do it and I think
I'm doing it wrong do you go back why
I'm doing it wrong hey Hilda tell me
about your friend yeah oh no I do that I
do that I always get chastised I do that
too
I was I cut my balls in my dick and I
cut like I don't cup I let it [ __ ] I
wish I could write it down yeah that's a
big no-no for girls especially well I
don't have a vagina but you know what
there was this one time I first started
dating where the ball smelled a little
bit like hole and that's when I figured
that he probably was about to friend
whoa whoa anyway baby I'm not talking
anymore okay can I tell I think I've had
it it's embarrassing yeah yeah what it's
over in college once I had a girl who
was going down on me and she was like
it's a little and I she was doing some
ball work yeah and she was like it's a
little like spicy like what yeah and I
say I don't know I was stumped by it and
then only years later did I realize I
probably got a little [ __ ] my balls and
oh yeah
the mask you they know can ask you this
point out what's more disturbing what's
more disturbing if you're eating a girl
out right and you smell poo or you smell
blood who is way worse who cares about
blood well they're both bad don't get
wrong blood has happened to me and it
was it was horrible odd and pool why you
got a 2 4 he was dead that's why
yeah anyway I'm done yeah
[Music]